un paso hacia la despenalización en
Estados Unidos el presidente Joe biden
anunció que indultará a los condenados
por delitos federales relacionados con
la posesión de marihuana en primer lugar
voy a perdonar todos los delitos
federales anteriores de Posesión simple
de marihuana hay miles de personas que
fueron condenadas previamente por
posesión simple y a las que se les puede
negar el empleo la vivienda o las
oportunidades educativas como resultado
mi indulto eliminará esta carga
la medida no cubre cargos relacionados
con la producción o posesión de
marihuana con la intención de
distribuirla y además aplica únicamente
a condenas federales sin embargo el
mandatario hizo un llamado para que los
gobernadores den el mismo paso hacia el
perdón de los delitos estatales para
muchos analistas se trata de una
decisión con fines electorales A pocas
semanas de unas elecciones de medio
término en las que los demócratas se
arriesgan a perder sus estrechas
mayorías legislativas
parte de una batería de medidas y además
de legislaciones que el presidente ha
ido tomando enfocándose en grupos que yo
pienso que los demócratas consideran que
son todavía gananciables en el marco de
la acumulación de apoyo electoral creo
que se ven forzados ante la nueva
crecida del costo de los combustibles
ante los nuevos efectos de las medidas
tizadas por la OPEP a improvisar algunas
medidas que tienden yo creo que a tocar
sectores electorales que los cuales el
voto demócrata se concentra en este caso
la población afroamericana no la
legislación sobre el consumo y posesión
de marihuana en Estados Unidos está
cambiando rápidamente ya son 19 los
estados en los que su uso medicinal y
recreacional es totalmente legal El
último en añadirse al grupo fue
Connecticut en junio algunos estados
como Minnesota Missouri Florida aceptan
su uso únicamente medicinal
mientras que esta sigue siendo ilegal en
Idaho Wyoming Kansas y Carolina del Sur